dix mille personnes de l'autre côté du
mur à berlin est il n'est jamais venu en
fait l'enquète a été très mal faite
c'est à dire qu on a demandé aux gens s
qui éventuellement vous seriez prêt à
retourner de l'autre côté à l'est et que
les réponses ont été évasif la seule
chose que nous avons pu voir aujourd'hui
c'était un corps où 80 personnes se
trouvaient qu'ils étaient venus de
l'ouest mais qu'ils étaient surtout des
marginaux c'est à dire des gens qui
n'avaient pas pu supporter la vie à
l'ouest qui revenait à l'est c'est tout
ce que nous avons trouvé pour l'instant
2-1 ces dons sont donc des intentions
mais qui ne se sont pas encore
concrétisés un pas encore bien alors
maintenant on parle de la porte de
brandebourg c'est vrai que c'est un
symbole c'est vrai aussi qu'on n'a pas
encore ouvert le passage a réexpliqué
nouveau film pourquoi c'est un symbole
cette porte de brandebourg écoutez c'est
un symbole parce que bon sur le plan
monument c'est simplement la copie de
l'entrée monumentale de l'acropole
d'athènes qui a été construite en 1788
par frédéric deux sous frédéric 2 mais
ce qui est important c'est qu'on a vu
ici stationner les armées prussiennes on
a vu ici défiler les armées
napoléoniennes et surtout les armées
nazies et en ce sens c'est un symbole le
jour où cette porte s'ouvrira ce sera
vraiment la fin de l'effondrement du mur
c'est pour ça qu'on va pas l'ouvrir
comme ça discrètement à la nuit on va
faire ça de façon très officielle et on
pense que cette ouverture pourrait avoir
lieu à l'occasion notamment de la
rencontre helmut kohl egon krenz ou
alors peut-être après le sommet bouche
gorbatchev pour donner un éclat un élan
total à cet effondrement du mur donc
pour l'instant n'a pas de date précise
ce sont des suppositions que l'on peut
faire n'est-ce pas là écoutez ce sont
des suppositions comme vous le voyez il
ya beaucoup de monde ici qui attend
l'ouverture il ya beaucoup de télévision
et puis je voulais signaler aussi que
les gens étaient très très être enfin
très sympathique vis-à-vis des
journalistes voilà par exemple la petite
ourse de berlats que m'a remis tout à
l'heure une berlinoise qui attend comme
nous ici devant la porte de brandebourg
l'ouverture et le passage de ce dernier
symbole voilà on a vu aussi des thermos
de café puis les vendeurs d'échelle qui
font fortune oui qui permet de regarder
de l'autre côté du mur en attendant
qu'il souffre de ce côté-ci la de la
porte de